yeah happy New Year look at you you look
so cute that's our new tagline new me in
23 for as long as it lasts maybe yeah
until next week exactly this is so 90s
I'm very good at this yes
retro I love the 90s I just love this
whole vibe but so wait what what did you
do over the holidays was it fun you go
anywhere so great I can't wait to hear
about yours my daughters came back from
college anybody have college age kids
here so you know it's it's a blessing
and a curse because they're used to
being in college where they go out very
late and then they come home and then I
can't go to bed till all the chickens
are into Roost so it's late nights a
lively household so much fun that
doesn't sound like vacation it's not
well and we didn't go on vacation
because with two in college and one in
high school our vacation is called
tuition
that's right all the money funnels we
stay right foot yeah that's kind of nice
though because you've all been you know
kind of separated for a bit so it's kind
of nice I gotta tell you I'm the
happiest when everybody's home when the
five of us are all together it's just my
favorite it really is a happier moment
probably before like two before two a.m
when I'm like and where are you now how
was yours how was the holidays with
little Bitties because you got to do the
whole you know Santa comes yeah the
Shelf yes it's all exciting and we we
actually split this year we did um we
were at my Ranch for a bit it looks like
Narnia it snows like so hardcore that
it's beautiful and um and then we were
in New York actually so we got to
experience New York they're like back
half of the vacation do the kids love
New York they love New York they love
going that's actually one of the reasons
why we split it this year and just just
didn't do it yeah well it's lit up and
for I mean for everyone but for kids
especially there's just like everything
is like magical looking so um but did
you all do any like film family
traditions like I know your mom like I
love your mom every time we tell stories
does she have any fun things so guys my
mom's name is bug and bug is in love
with Kelly I love she told me today she
said wear a lot of blush and talk slow
um I have all my mom's decorations when
I was a little girl in the 70s she like
hand painted stuff it was really big in
the 70s so I have like Christmas
Villages and all her old stuff then my
brother and I fight over and I got
everything yeah um but so I've got all
that up and then I used to do the
Christmas card or the holiday card which
I don't do anymore with pictures of the
kids because they're too old I Love a
Bad Card I like when you get a wonky
photo or my mom's bug would look
gorgeous and then my brother and I would
be like one eye shutter one time she cut
off my brother's head and put it on a
picture of me in high school though she
thought I looked really pretty so my
brother's ear this is the 70s there was
no computers or anything no Photoshop no
Photoshop his neck was really pointy and
weird and the ear was off and my brother
was like this is not a joke love the
Hoovers yeah this is not a joke I've
talked about this on the show before my
mom used to do that she'd cut us out and
we never went on vacation because we
were poor but she'd put us like in a
beautiful destination she put pictures
if like wasn't that exciting like yeah
do you remember the mountains you
remember the mountains there was a
funeral home in Atlanta Georgia near
where I grew up that had a beautiful
Segway
that had beautiful grounds like huggable
grounds we took our Christmas card here
every year at the funeral home and Mom
act like bugged it like it was our
backyard and there's my brother and I
outside I can't remember the name of it
you took your Christmas family photo at
a at a funeral place year after year
Kelly we follow these right the way
through until finally my brother and I
are like Mom this is weird and then we
we leaned in we're like saddle up the
car kids and I took my kids there I'm
like I know where we're going
Patterson's funeral home that was the
name oh my God that's hysterical so many
family traditions are being started
right now
the grounds were stunning oh that's kind
of cool though it's prepared in a
beautiful place but truthfully I'm so
happy now I'm gonna get emotional to
have bug right she's 83.
um Dad Bucky's 88 and like I just I'm in
that age group where my friends are
losing their parents and so I just feel
I'm in that age group like people are
passing away and it's yeah it's so hard
I don't like it at all yeah the
Traditions are I don't let them out of
my sight I follow them around around I
just love love it all stalk them I stalk
them I'm connected it's nice though to
carry on those Traditions too that's
really really cool it really is I love
it
the favorite people to see on access are
like on a red carpet event you're the
same as me right we are so lucky to get
to meet so many so cool um and it's
always a pinch me moment like it's I'm
never above that but lately it's the
really normal people normal people like
ourselves doing extraordinary things I
just interviewed this woman yeah
quadriplegic lives in a van that she
designed herself she serves she skis she
goes up she has a special way to move
around a hike up a mountain gorgeous I'm
so in love with this woman I'm like now
that's the human spirit that interests
me but if you want to talk celebrities
who do we want to talk to no no I love
that you said that because it is it is
awesome to do all the celebrity things
too even on this show but it's cool you
meet these people and I feel like in the
news we see like just so much
Devastation which we need to seize
because we want to progress we want to
change things we need to see it but it's
overwhelming yeah and it's sad so it's
like nice when you meet someone like
that and you're like geez like you are
killing it because
um there was nothing about her that was
downtrodden or feeling sorry for herself
I mean this woman has it going I want to
say she was 32 years old the van and was
tripped out and fabulous I mean white
water rafting surfing skiing she has
somebody had built her all these really
makes me feel like a loser we can go on
the fast walk with her oh my God but I
just think of the human spirit and how
tremendous it was that does feel really
good it is awesome to do the celebrity
things people like you you know love and
movies or music or something I geek out
those moments are like really special
that's why I like this show so much on
New Year's do you do resolutions like
are you like okay this is what I'm gonna
do here's what I do I don't do
resolutions I do better I'm like what am
I going to be better at because I don't
know why I do them because I don't do
any of them never learn Spanish
completely I'm like so half it's like
I'm just this person that's like I'll
accept like almost there like you know
like it's like average is fine like I
just I never do it do you do no I just
try and do better better yeah my latest
with better
um water is a thing I'm gonna try to
drink more water you are what where I
thought wait you're like the healthiest
person ever and you don't talk you're
not hydrated no I was thinking I love
coffee which is why I'm always
subjective of coffee I tried to do the
oat milk thing I'm back to my coffee
mate oh yeah my almond milk I just a tad
bit of honey it's a little honey okay
I'll try yeah but I just realized with
work and stuff I wasn't drinking as much
water so that's on my list to do that's
a good read more yeah I'm fairly into
both but I'm starting I love reading I'm
so glad you said that I love reading but
I never have time anymore this is me I
opened the book and I was like I'm just
gonna read it and then you're asleep
I get in bed and I'm just like and I'm
and I'm always watching things too
because we're interviewing people so
you're always like watching things to
cut you know you want to obviously be
informed about what you're interviewing
them about and like by the time I get to
like a book I've been dying to finish
I'd literally fall asleep after this I
got a book and I'm not even a Kindle
girl I like to open up no it has to be
Tanto it smells I like the book thing
all right we'll get in a book club of
two and we'll keep a rather encountable
one book a year one page a day we'll get
there one year one a year guys hold us
account I used to read so much I used to
but I was just no time I know it was a
sad clap sorry
I'm gonna give you an average clap
because that's not really great ladies
okay so we touched on taking care of our
but I know that you have a particular
message that you want to talk about
right yes Kelly I want to say it was
maybe last time I was on you and I were
talking about this and I don't know if
we have a picture control room but six
of my bridesmaids that were in my
wedding all were diagnosed with breast
cancer look at this picture I don't know
if it was covered on the show but we
talked about it and I that is crazy and
when you think about that and uh most of
them stage one and they've all beat it
oh look how cute they are and then
little la la down there the one at the
bottom she's actually pregnant
um stage two and it's one of those
things and so please everybody get
checked also in this picture my mother
is a Survivor bug my mother-in-law Mama
Sullivan a Survivor but is that a weird
there's something about that picture
that really hit me I was down in Atlanta
with this one on the end little Gene
bird on the end we were taking care of
her with her drains and everything and I
left to come back to California and then
Lisa on the end texted and said I've got
stage two I'm like no no You Mean Gene
we were just there she's fine she's like
no me so all of my best friends I don't
understand this and we don't live we all
live across the country this isn't like
we live live in one spot yeah insane
Kelly so and they all get their
mammograms or ultrasounds everything but
they're catching it but they're catching
it early but it's really scary so yeah
get checked stay on it yeah and stay on
it um you know I don't know if you're
supposed to go younger now or maybe
that's a colonoscopy I get confused with
these things
40 now I I go before I'm even supposed
to go because you you should know your
family's history because I know polyps
can run our family so I had a
colonoscopy way before I was supposed to
because I just if you have the means and
you can get it done it's like do it and
y'all do it you think weird it's nothing
weird about it get in and make sure I'm
gonna be honest with you I don't
remember it except for the good drugs
I came out very happy I don't know what
happened in there I won the best
colonoscopy or the best whatever the
colon award oh you had a really yeah I
would great one I had a great one too
yeah and when I went in y'all I was
lined up we won we got good-looking
colons yeah yeah and that's hot
is incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]